choosing an ipad just got more difficult
now that apple released the new ipad
mini 6 and the budget ipad 9. so what
i'm going to do in this video is lay out
all of the differences to help you
decide which one you should buy i've got
every single ipad in apple's current
ipad lineup right in front of me
including the new 10.2 inch ipad 9
the redesigned ipad mini 6 the ipad air
4 which i'm actually using as the
teleprompter right now
the 11 inch m1 ipad pro as well as the
12.9 inch model so let's get right into
this comparison comparing the designs
the ipad 9 is the only one that hasn't
moved over to the modern flat sided
design language which obviously looks
much nicer and makes the ipads feel more
future proof matching up to the latest
iphones the ipad 9 is also the only one
that doesn't get a nice looking camera
bump so it's the only one without a 12
megapixel rear camera sitting at just 8
megapixels so it's the only one that
cannot record at 4k and then the ipad
pro gets the additional ultra wide
camera and a lidar scanner on the rear
for use with augmented reality apps now
both the ipad mini and the air get touch
id built into the power button compared
to the ipad 9 which has touch id built
into the front with the home button
which definitely doesn't look as nice
with those square display corners but
the ipad pro actually gets face id just
like you get on an iphone which in my
opinion is the best solution because it
authenticates automatically which is so
much more convenient and another thing
you'll notice on the larger ipads is the
smart connector either on the side or on
the back and this is used to connect
accessories like the magic keyboard case
which i have right over here which
basically turns it into a laptop
replacement because it has a built-in
trackpad that works really well and of
course the mini doesn't get this because
it's obviously too small to support a
decent sized keyboard and that small
size is also why the volume buttons have
been relocated from the side like on the
ipad pro to the top because that is
where you have the new apple pencil
magnetic charging connector to basically
support the second gen apple pencil and
as you can see it takes up literally the
entire side which is why they move the
volume buttons compared to the ipad pro
where you still have a little bit room
to change the volume and with that said
the new budget ipad 9 is the only ipad
that supports the older apple pencil
which recharges by plugging it into the
lightning port which is also only on the
ipad 9 since the rest of the ipad lineup
has moved on to a usb type-c port and
even better an all-out thunderbolt port
on the ipad pro models which actually
supports hubs that we've used on the m1
mac mini but i guess at least one saving
grace for the budget ipad 9 is that it's
the only one that still features a
headphone jack for those who really care
about that now as far as the speakers
every ipad except for the ipad 9 again
features speakers on both the top and
the bottom which gives you true stereo
sound when in landscape mode while the
ipad pro is actually the only one that
has quad speakers so one two three four
for even better sound and a louder
experience just hear it for yourself
[Music]
so
[Music]
so as you've just heard the ipad 9
doesn't sound as good because the audio
only comes out of one side compared to
both sides on the rest of the ipads and
you probably also noticed that the pros
sound much better and louder especially
on the massive 12.9 inch now moving over
to the front the ipad 9 is the only one
to feature the old square corner display
design compared to nice rounded corners
of even bezels all around on the rest of
the ipad lineup which obviously gives
you a much more immersive experience and
that display on the 12.9 inch model is
absolutely massive and because of that
it's by far the least comfortable to use
as a regular tablet so i honestly think
it's meant to be used with a keyboard
case like apple's magic keyboard
basically creating a laptop replacement
now on the other hand you've got the
ipad mini which is perfect for tablet
use both for kids and adults who just
want to browse the web or play games on
the couch or literally anywhere else and
i'd say that the other three offer a
really good balance between portability
and the option to use like a laptop if
you get a keyboard case like the
logitech combo or folio touch which also
packs a built-in trackpad now as far as
the display quality all of the ipads
except for the budget ipad 9 come with
laminated displays which means that the
display and cover glass are glued
together forming a more solid display
that improves black contrast levels and
doesn't have a visible gap between the
two layers like you get on the ipad 9.
on top of that the ipad 9 is the only
one that doesn't feature an
anti-reflective coating which you might
even be able to tell just from looking
at these two displays and it also
doesn't support dci p3 colors for a more
color accurate display as you see in
this example where it can't show this
specific shade of red as far as the
maximum brightness the ipad pros get
brighter specifically 600 nits when in
regular use compared to 500 on the other
ipads however the 12.9 inch ipad pro is
the only one that features apple's
latest xdr display which uses mini led
technology to get much brighter when
viewing hdr video and movie content all
the way up to 600 nits peak brightness
while also giving you the best and
deepest contrast levels you can get the
only issue is that you can sometimes
notice a blooming or halo glow effect
around bright white sections of the
display especially when the lights are
turned off now on top of all of that the
ipad pros come with the 120hz pro motion
feature which allows the displays to
refresh at up to 120 hertz giving you
much more smooth animations and
scrolling compared to the rest of the
ipads that are stuck at 60 hertz as you
can see in these slow mo clips this
feature alone is the reason why i
personally will never buy an ipad
without 120hz refresh rate especially
since i just upgraded to the iphone 13
pro max which also supports promotion oh
and by the way this feature on the ipad
pros also reduces apple pencil latency
making it feel super smooth and natural
now before i get into the performance i
want to ask you guys to go ahead and
subscribe because we've got a lot more
content coming to you guys including
ipads m1x macbook pros and everything
else so we would really appreciate it
because we're trying to hit a million
before the end of this year so thank you
guys now i do want to mention that the
ipad air is the only one that doesn't
come with the new 12 megapixel ultra
wide selfie camera which gives you a
whole new perspective and it also gives
you center stage support which
automatically keeps your face in the
center of the frame which is really nice
and before the performance there's also
differences in the microphone quality so
here's a quick clip so you can hear it
for yourself this is the microphone
quality on the new 10.2 inch ipad 9.
this is the microphone quality on the
new ipad mini 6. this is the microphone
quality on the 10.9 inch ipad air 4.
this is the microphone quality on the 11
inch m1 ipad pro and finally this is a
microphone quality on the 12.9 inch ipad
pro all right getting into performance
the budget ipad 9 gets the a13 chip the
ipad air gets the a14 the new mini
actually gets the latest a15 which is a
little bit ironic and the ipad pros get
the m1 chip directly from the m1 max as
far as the ram the ipad 9 gets three
gigabytes the mini and the air get four
and the pros actually get a really solid
8 gigabytes of ram with the option of
getting up to 16 gigs if you buy the one
terabyte of storage model which is
insanely expensive now in terms of the
raw cpu performance in geekbench 5
they're all incredibly powerful in terms
of single core performance with the
biggest outlier being the ipad 9. now
this is going to give all of them really
good web browsing performance with the
new ipad mini 6 being surprisingly
almost as fast as the m1 ipad pro
however in the multi-core performance
test you can see where the ipad pro is
getting a massive lead and surprisingly
the mini with the new a15 chip is barely
faster than the a14 in the ipad air now
in terms of raw graphics performance the
ipad 9 starts to fall way behind and
once again the mini is just barely
faster than the air with the ipad pro
gaining an absolutely massive lead so
that brings us to a real world gaming
stress test where the m1 ipad pro pulls
even further ahead but the other ipads
aren't necessarily that bad because even
the budget ipad 9 ran a lot of the most
common games at a perfect and consistent
60 fps at maxed out graphic settings
with no issues including games like call
of duty mobile pokemon unite and league
of legends wild rift it even handled
gangshin impact the most demanding ios
game ever surprisingly well at maxed out
graphics settings but it did suffer from
fps drops that you don't experience on
the other more powerful ipads it was
also not nearly as comfortable as the
other ipads to hold in your hand in game
because of the large top and bottom
bezel which pushes the on-screen
controls further away from the edges of
the ipad making it less comfortable but
by far the most comfortable ipad for
gaming is the new ipad mini because of
the compact size which makes controlling
it very easy and the much lighter weight
making it the most perfect gaming tablet
i have ever used but because of the m1
chip and pro motion display the ipad pro
can actually handle a solid 120 fps in
call of duty mobile as you can see in
this video from golden reviewer and that
is obviously only possible on the ipad
pro models now moving on to some of the
spec differences the budget ipad gets
bluetooth 4.2 compared to 5.0 on the
rest of the ipads and it's the only one
that doesn't support wi-fi six but only
the pros and the new mini have the
option of 5g connectivity now this year
the budget ipad finally comes with 64
gigabytes of base storage making it a
much better value since it matches the
mini and the air but the pros actually
get 128 gigs at the base price which is
definitely a nice upgrade so with all of
that said and compared let's get right
into my purchasing recommendations
starting off with who should be buying
the basic ipad 9. if you don't really
care about having the latest design and
the best display quality then i'd
honestly recommend this budget ipad
because you can obviously get it for
much less than the other models and the
performance is more than good enough for
most people it also has the benefit of
being turned into a decent laptop
replacement thanks to the smart
connector and of course it has the
headphone jack for those who really want
to use it but unfortunately the speakers
aren't that great now if you do care
about getting a more future proof design
that looks more modern with the rounded
quarter display and one that comes with
modern specs and features like the usb
type c port the 2nd gen apple pencil
support and the true stereo speakers in
landscape mode then i would recommend
getting a more expensive ipad like the
ipad mini 6. this one is really meant
for people who already have a laptop or
computer for their productivity work and
they just want a tablet to use on the
couch for tablet things like surfing the
web and using social media and just like
i mentioned before i think this is by
far the best tablet for gaming because
of the compact and lightweight size
combined with the impressive a15 chip
that handles any game out there with
ease it's also by far the best option
for kids again because of the smaller
size now if you want something exactly
like the mini but with a larger more
immersive display then the ipad air is
the next step up and the added benefit
of the smart connector means you can
also use it as a laptop replacement just
keep in mind that for the extra 100
dollars you don't get any extra base
storage and it actually comes with the
older and slightly slower a14 chip and
it doesn't come with features like the
12 megapixel ultra wide selfie camera
and the rear facing flash and i would
honestly steer people away from buying
the ipad air right now because we're
expecting it to get updated in the
springtime next year to add in those
missing features and get updated with
the a15 chip and another huge reason is
that it's only 200 less expensive than
the ipad pro and it lacks a ton of
features including the 120hz display the
quad speakers the 600 nits of brightness
the extra cameras on the back the better
microphones optional 5g connectivity the
thunderbolt port the extra 4 gigabytes
of ram and of course the massive
difference in performance which all
together make it much more future proof
so if you're already spending 600 bucks
on the air the ipad pro is a no-brainer
for 200 more since it also comes with
double the storage space 128 gigs
instead of 64. and that 120 hertz
promotion feature is an absolute game
changer and then of course the 12.9 inch
ipad pro for 1100
is meant for the real professionals out
there who want to use it for work or
professional editing or simply anyone
who really cares about having the best
display out there thanks to the new mini
led tech or maybe you just like the
massive display size so with all that
said let me just make it simple for you
if you want a reliable ipad but don't
want to spend a ton of cash just go for
the budget ipad 9. if you want something
small and compact but very powerful and
reliable for everyday casual use then
buy the new ipad mini but out of all of
these ipads i would honestly recommend
the 11 inch ipad pro because it gives
you by far the best value for everything
you're getting making it the most future
proof for the amount of cash especially
since it's on sale on amazon right now
for 750 dollars so hopefully this video
helped you make a decision and if it did
i'm gonna put links to the best deals on
all of these ipads down in the
description below and be sure to click
that circle above to subscribe for more
helpful videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]